こんにちは
肇社長です
今回
動画の
タイトルにもあると知っ
私から
皆様に
お願いがございます
皆さんの力で
動画作ってください
初めて朝同コンテストネイマール22
3年前にも同じことをやったような気が
するんですけどもそれの新しいバージョン
でございますこんにちははじめ撮像です皆
さんにどうかを編集してくださいっていう
ところだしたところめさくさ好評だったん
ですよそりゃもう凄い盛り上がったので
ちょっと今回第2弾ってわけじゃないです
けど同じような数で皆さんに私はじめ冊を
が映像を渡してその動画をぜひ皆さんで
編集していただきたいという内容になって
おります今回のコンテスト
ほぼ一緒はいそして今回皆さんすごいです
よ
なんと協賛企業さんでいらっしゃいます
殿下がお日さんですありがとうございます
遊びの編集ソフトといえば
premiere pro 皆さん動画
編集するときどうやってされますか無料の
編集アプリスマホで編集いろいろあると
思うんですけどもどうしても作りたいもの
が表現できない方いらっしゃると思います
僕はプレミアプロ使ったことあるんです
けどもアドベさんに聞いたんですか
プレミアブルは動画平州に必要な機能が
すべて付いているということで思いついた
アイディアを形にして1本への高い
クオリティの動画制作ができるということ
なんです動画編集
めんどくさい難しいばかりいます僕も10
年間動画編集してわかるんですけどもう
難しい作業と駒大日もめっちゃ音ですよ
動画編集でも超初心者でも難しい編集が
簡単になる便利な機能がいくつかあります
僕がすごい便利だなって思って昨日は音声
からの自動文字起こししゃべった言葉が
そのまま物に起こされるんですよめっちゃ
楽なんです写してはないそして自動で
キャプションせいぜいしてくるんですって
これどういうことかというと喋って言葉が
そのはテロップになると言う
youtube やってる人からせると
わかると思うんですけどめーちゃくちゃ
便利な機能ですがちな話僕の周りの
クリエイターさん多分父8割ぐらいの人は
もうあ取りで編集されています好きている
人が多いとどういうことが起きるかという
ともちろん後美腰の使い方がいいのもある
んですけども
それだけじゃないんですよいろんな人が
使っているので使い方のブログとか動画が
めちゃくちゃたくさん出てるんですよなの
で編集でやりたいことどうしようかなって
困った時も検索したり調べたらすぐどう
やってるが出てくるのでそれもまた便利な
ところの一つだと思いますそして今回なん
と特設サイト内にチュートリアルがあり
ますので初めて行ってみようという人は
ぜひそうそれを参考にしてみてください
なんかそれ講師の方が僕の素材で実際に
編集されてるみたいなんですごい参考に
なると思いますぜひ見てください今回の
コンテスト premiere pro を
持つでない方も7日間の無料体験が出来
ますので動画編集したことある人ばっかり
ではなく動画編集したことない人にも参加
していただきたい
皆さんにも動画編集の面白さを知って
いただきたいというのもあるので僕が+
動画を好き勝手に編集していただきたいと
思っておりますもう何でもアリですよ
テロップでたくさんなんか色々書いても
よし効果音で挟め茶にしてもよし私た映像
強に改造してもよしやばい技術を持ちの方
もいるでしょうそれを自由に駆使しても
よしです表現の葉ははん
皆さん次第です
はいしてませんの寸前に全県めちゃくちゃ
面白かったんですよはるかに僕の想像量が
者作品ばっかり生まれてきたので今回も
それは是非見たいなと思ってございは作ら
せていただきましたそれで皆様にお渡し
する素材だけもありますのでそちら見て
いただきたいと思います
どうぞ
認証であります
ver
ben b こんにちはー
是非れていて誰ねぇ
ぜひ行っの
農家はいさー
[拍手]
うまい
はいいかがだったでしょうか一応横画面と
タテ画面今回準備させていただきましたお
好きな方を選んで自由に調理しちゃって
くださいで何度なくのテーマがあるんです
けども前回まあ改造でしたが今回神編集と
いうテーマでやらせていただきます兵種
っていうのは技術だけじゃないんですね
もちろん技術もいっそうだと思いますよ
技術も大事ですけど
僕はこの約10年間 youtube 活動
で思ったことは
編集は
被害です
初めての方でも大丈夫
気合があこれは者技術でした
気合いがあれば必ず素敵な映像を作ると
思いますやったことないなあと思う方も
是非今回なんか攻めてはいかがでしょうか
そしてで私が面白いこれ指摘だすげーどう
やってんだこれ俺にはできない神ゲー臭だ
と思ったそんな素晴らしい作品はですね
是非私の動画のハーフ票会で一緒に見たい
と思っております
さらにその中で特に僕がすごいなと思った
5作品にははじめ賞として
証言ズーの塩プレゼントします
5名なのでも50万円ですね
も積み上がったでしょう
そしてそれとは別にアイディアそうですね
はこれすげーアイディアだと思った3名の
方には遊びクリエイティブクラウド
コンプリートプラン1年ライセンス
プレゼントします
[音楽]
そして参加賞の方抽選で5名の方には遊び
クリエイティブクラウドコンプリート
プラン半年ライセンスをプレゼントいたし
ます
これもすごい
合計金額
100万円超えてます本当に素敵な先に
作られた方にはもう商品が出るので皆さん
是非がんばってみてください動画のルール
なんですけどもざっくりと大事なことだけ
説明させていただきます大巻環境です
2022年8月の204日から9月の26
日までとさせていただきますまあ約1か月
ぐらいあるので結構凝ったものが作れるか
なと思います動画のシャックが60秒以内
にしてくださいこれルールですお願いし
ますそして編集ソフトは adobe 限定
でお願いします保存を使わないでください
ぱどビザがおります
して素材ですね編集するにあたって素材と
かあると思うんですよ音楽とか画像とか
それ全部著作権フリーのもの自分で作った
もの自分で撮ったものとか使うといいと
思いますもっと食わせるは動画の概要欄に
特設サイトがありますのでそちらから是非
確認してください続いて応募方法です
はじめ社長のツイッターとコンテストの
公式ツイなうをフォローしてください
そしてハッシュタグはじめで遊ぼう
ハッシュたく premiere pro
をつけて twitter に作品の説明
をつけて投稿してください twitter
に動画を撮っ家でもいいんですけども
youtube にアップしてその
youtube の url をその
ツイートに入れちゃっても大丈夫です
そして結果発表の日時なんですけども10
月の下旬以降に派図3冊をチャンネルで
公開予定でございますみなさん素敵な発表
会ぜひ楽しみにしていてください
まぁ今回のです編集を楽しんでほしいです
皆さんにさっきも言いましたけども編集
技術とかも大事ですけど僕は編集綺麗だと
思ってるんで気合でここまで聴いてると
思ってるんで僕はぜひぜひ赤身編集ミスっ
てくださいっは皆さん
ヌーをお待ちしております
ジャンヌ
[音楽]
うぉっ
は